[Music]
so uh joe can you please do the audience
a favor and uh explain what a honey trap
is a honey trap is when you have
a beautiful girl
going like hey what's up and you're like
me
and you're at the bar
and then she comes up to you
and then you guys have some drinks
and then she goes let's go up to your
place or mine and i'm like whatever's
more comfortable and then you had a sex
good answer
right
and you it's amazing and then wait
what's amazing the sex is amazing and
then you're like cuddling in bed and
you're talking you might be drinking
coffee like this
there you go
so
tell me about
you know
your business and what you do and you
start talking and before you know it
you're like [ __ ] telling her all
these secrets and then the next day
you're trapped [ __ ] because she
was a spy and she just [ __ ] got all
of your [ __ ] and then now you're gonna
die oh she honey did i forget the part
that i was a secret agent yeah wow
she's like so like you work at like the
nuclear plant huh that's cool
it's like what it was like what are the
codes you think
[Laughter]
so you're the honey trap no she was the
honey trap oh but he's also a secret
agent but i was the secret agent that
she took all the secrets from she
reversed
i got double-oh-seven seven hundred then
yeah cause you guys i was solving
hundreds wait have any of you been
actually honey trapped
catfish
i don't have an objective catfish reason
yeah but i don't think i have anything
that people want yeah you gotta have you
know so it's like you're as you're
hey put your net worth out right now
dude popular youtubers probably get
probably have this happen all the time
like real popular ones like you know the
real popular guys
the one with more subscribers
i heard that the russian honey traps are
the most dangerous one because like uh
during the soviet union era they would
train these special spy girls and you
know russian girls are [ __ ] hot yeah
or the red sparrows like yeah what's her
face movie naked jennifer lawrence yeah
that's the exactly naked precedes
jennifer lawrence they train him to
write dick so good job
[Laughter]
they are the queen of seductions you
know there's a seduction school you know
damn dude it's
so good once you get up don't you get in
bed with them oh man that's a true honey
trap because you sticking all over that
honey you're sticking all that honey and
according to the bart to the burp test
which is how nice is that ass how many
seconds until i bust yeah it's like a
good five seconds
only
i actually wanted to be cia just so i
can be honey trapped by a russian red
sparrow but you would die afterwards
well it's mostly because he said that he
didn't make cia
that was his that's what he said
yeah it was it was an eight-minute
interview you did not tell them dude
the interview was actually mostly judges
getting coffee before they even asked
some questions and then it was about two
minutes of actual he made them wait he's
like hey you mind if i get some coffee
he's like he's like oh cool he's like
i'm gonna make this real quick and then
they're actually they're waiting for the
microwave i mean they had a free [ __ ]
coffee bar dude i get it anyway yeah
when they're like yeah you guys why do
you want to join us and i'm like oh dude
i you guys always get honey trapped by
like the hottest [ __ ] spies yeah i'm
glad that um the russian one didn't get
hired forever he made it to the second
round if they're hiring for a
sacrificial person to get honey trap but
he has no codes or anything they're just
like yeah she's gonna [ __ ] kill you
imagine they think they got it we just
give them fake codes out f4 that's it
imagine someone like joe
someone like joe making cia getting
killed in action and they put that star
on the wall and we all know what a
[ __ ] idiot he is
[Laughter]
we're like yeah well they tied his shoes
together he fell down the stairs
he gets a [ __ ] gold star on the wall
dude like did i have a [ __ ] photo
like all square and [ __ ] and then like
you guys know me agent catfish they tied
his velcro shoes together and he fell
out of
that's great counter measures for honey
traps though
so this is about the incredible story of
uh teen honey trap assassins oh my god
who lured dozens of nazis to their
deaths after joining the resistance
that's pretty ballers
they were also pedophile hunters uh i
guess so what's the age of consent there
though in nazi germany
ah that's true i don't know
you're like you're seventeen never mind
i have morals
i have more of them that kind of nazi
they did do their luck and morals
that's what they're every time they say
so these two teenagers their identities
have finally been revealed after all
this time uh again i hope i don't
butcher these things freddie overstegan
was just 14 years old when she joined
the dutch resistance along with her
older sister truce who was 16. as
hitler's german uh army invaded the
netherlands in 1940. oh that's a dope
that's a dope photo and now i have to
show that that's so baller
this is gonna be a movie the honey traps
group photo all right there it is now i
have to show it because
this is woman empowerment have an ak
wow
what is she holding a gun that's a gun
she's holding her husband's gun that's
tight
so do you cross the line with that one
that was crazy
[Laughter]
don't talk about that like it's the
jewish stuff yeah like whatever but but
what that [ __ ] said crazy
you cannot say this here this is a safe
this is not in germany
it's not the germany bots
you're also cutting edge
we are so progressive
whatever
[Laughter]
they're very lazy fair about it oh my
god
they're trying to be new age dude come
on so the pair
raised by their communist working-class
mother was sent on dangerous
assassination missions or were tasked
with leading german soldiers astray uh
as part of a deadly resistance cell and
due to their age freddie andrews rarely
raised suspicion and were able to
discreetly follow targets on their bikes
with pistols hidden in their baskets
before gunning them down that's so dope
so she were killed
the teens would kill him gangsters or or
keeping a lookout for other resistance
fighters wow oh i thought they were like
luring them and then and then like and
then their like brother would come and
stab him in the neck or something they
would kill him these are like 80s movie
assassins wow yeah like the nun with the
gun they also used dynamite to blow up
bridges and railway lines as well as
saving countless jewish children's lives
by smuggling them out of the country or
helping them escape nazi pills are that
a movie about this is gonna be a movie
it they probably will it's a tarantino
movie already yeah this is so dope this
is really cool the siblings were
considered to be so lethal that to this
day no one knows the exact amount of
nazis and dutch informers the pair were
able to assassinate that's ty speaking
after truth's death aged 92 her daughter
hanny menger revealed my mother drove
the bicycle and freddie sat on the back
and was shooting because they were girls
no one ever noticed them
sounds like privilege
that sounds privileged that's crazy
we didn't know
we didn't know they were going to shoot
us
we respect women they were so cute
we respect them they don't want to use
guns
that's what they would say that's what
the nazis would say that makes sense i
saw this one video of um a hostage
situation in china
and they use a lot of like these dummy
assassin cops are like you know they
they're undercover but most of them
the video that i saw were just like
regular like cute little girls or like
women right they're just walking down
the street with like a basket or
whatever and as the [ __ ] whole
hostage situation is going down they
just smoke them boom whoa there's no
like try to keep them alive or anything
yeah the house is negotiated like i'm
gonna [ __ ] kill you [ __ ]
wait can i get a helicopter no i'm
killing you guess what game over
[ __ ]
tick-tock i'm coming upstairs
dude they'll be holding someone with a
knife
and everyone's like oh no and then this
lady's just walking by with a basket and
just wow and then the the guy takes them
yeah it's not it's so crazy
i want to see those videos yeah you
should it's very exciting so in an early
assignment the siblings were asked to
flirt with german soldiers so that a
nazi warehouse could be burnt to the
ground while later being tasked with
seducing a high-ranking soldier luring
him into the woods where he would be
shot dead
and speaking to vice in 2016 freddie
said truce had met him in an expensive
bar
seduced him much like joe was explaining
and then took him for a walk in the
woods she was like want to go for a
stroll and of course he wanted to a
deadly stroll
[Laughter]
breaks the fourth of what [ __ ]
it's training day [ __ ]
did you just break the fourth wall
no no
then then they would uh then they ran
into someone which seemed to be a
coincidence but he was one of ours and
then shots were fired so that man never
knew what hit him so in the exact kind
of scenario like they would you know
just play this entire [ __ ] concept
out where this kid brings out a [ __ ]
grown-ass soldier and then gets [ __ ]
killed in the back of the head
yeah
that's actually really cool it is huh
that's like one of the coolest things
that's why everyone from that generation
thought like
everyone else was a bunch of little
[ __ ]
dude for real that world war ii era is
crazy you guys did you guys hear what
will be goldberg said about yeah dude
that's a while yeah did she get
cancelled for it because she basically
said someone was asked she was like
she's like the holocaust wasn't about
race
and everyone's like what what was it
about them she was saying it was like
it's they're both
two groups of white people about being
human each other to each other so it was
like yeah it was in humanity being about
humanity and i'm like yo they live but
they didn't consider jewish white so
what does she talk about but it could
also be both it doesn't matter because
after she said it i bet you the view
audience was like
one person like kind of agreed like oh
yeah and then after it all set in joey
was like yeah wait explain yeah yeah
wait uh
say that again
yeah it was weird that is weird and then
she had apologized she's like i
understand i offended i was insensitive
it is about race like you know [ __ ] they
hitler basically said we're the inferior
race
fear your race [ __ ] it's
training day
that was like
that was mine comp like he wrote it down
yeah it's about race
my race is better
[Music]
[Music]
you